معنا من رم الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد اهلا بك اذا اجتماع دون اتخاذ
قرارات بخصوص هذه الحرب المستمره ماذا نقل
عن كواليس هذا الاجتماع وما شهده من
نقاشات الجديد هو ان هذا الاجتماع للطاقم
الوزاري الامني السياسي المصغر المعروف
بالكابينه امتد حتى ساعات الفجر وهي المره
الاولى التي يبحث فيها ما بات يعرف بال
الاسرائيليه لليوم التالي لقطاع غزه اليوم
التالي للحرب بمعنى هل ستبقى اسرائيل هناك
قوه احتلال مسيطره طيله الوقت او كما يقول
نتنياهو انها ستواصل سيطرتها الامنيه على
قطاع غزه
وستحل الاداره المدنيه
لقوه او لجهه اخرى ام انها ستنسحب وتتركه
في حاله فراغ هذه هذا الاجتماع هو الاول
الذي يطرح فيه نتنياهو هذه القضيه بعد
مماطله امتدت لاكثر من شهر رغم انه كانت
هناك طلبات من ضباط ومسؤولين عسكريين
وامنين كبار وكذلك من الولايات المتحده
بالاضافه بطبيعه الحال للوزراء من معسكر
الدوله تحديدا جانس وايزن كوت كان هناك
طلب بان يكون هناك افق سياسيه لهذا الهجوم
الحربي الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه والى ماذا
سينتهي هذه الليله تم طرح الموضوع لكن
تداخلت الامور في الجلسه مع امور اخرى
وانتهى دون ان يتم اتخاذ اي قرارات
ونتنياهو ابلغهم بانه سيعود ويطرح الموضوع
مجددا في اجتماعات لاحقه من اجل بحث وحسم
هذا الامر كي يتم تحديد موقف اسرائيلي
خاصه وان هناك ضغط امريكي وضغط من قيادات
الجيش وكذلك الاجهزه الامنيه بهذا الخصوص
المواقف الاسرائيليه بهذا الشان وهو ما
يخيف نتنياهو تتراوح بين ما يطرحه وزراء
من امثال التوام سموتريتش وبن كفير من
الصهيونيه الدينيه وعظمه يهوديه الذين
يقولون بان اسرائيل يجب ان تستولي على
قطاع غزه وتقوم بتهجير قصري لمئات الالوف
منه ومنهم من يدعو لاعاده بناء الاستيطان
فيه وابقائه تحت السيطره والاداره
الاسرائيليه وهناك اتجاه اخر يقول بان
اسرائيل يجب ان تدعم اقامه هيئه او سلطه
تشارك فيها السلطه الفلسطينيه بعد ان يتم
تغيير بنيتها وتغيير طريقه ادائها مع جهات
دوليه وعربيه اخرى تقوم في ضروره ادارته
مدنيا فقط بينما ابقاء الصلاحيات الامنيه
لاسرائيل لفتره طويله نتنياهو كان قد روج
قبل نحو شهر بانه لديه خطه بان من يقوم
باداره الشان المدني في قطاع غزه هم
ممثلين عن عشائر وعائلات هناك لكن هذا
يبدو انه فشل من بدايته وكان نتنياهو قد
اعلن بانه لن يكون هناك لا فتح ستان ولا
حماس ستان في اشاره الى انه يرفض وجود
فصائل فلسطينيه سواء اسلاميه او وطنيه من
منظمه التحرير في اداره القطاع لكن حتى
هذا الان حتى الان ليس هناك تصور اسرائيلي
واضح بهذا الخصوص واسرائيل تدرك
بانها بان نهايه الحرب ما تزال بعيده وان
كانت المؤشرات التي يتحدث عنها الجيش من
خلال مصادره في الايام الاخيره وصباح هذا
اليوم تقول بانه يواصل قتاله الضاري ويحقق
تقدما كبيرا في منطقه جنوبي قطاع غزه
تحديدا في منطقه خان يونس وغربها تحت
الارض وفوقها يقول كما ذكرت انه يواصل
القتال ولكنه في الوقت ذاته يتحدث ايضا عن
خسائره في هذه المعارك وهذه العمليات
العسكريه ما نقراه الان على الشاشه في خبر
عاجل الزائر هو بيان جديد للجيش
الاسرائيلي فيه احصاء جديد لمن يسقطون من
جنود وضباط اسرائيليين جرحى في هذه
العمليات يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي الان صحيح
هناك عمليات فقط وليد الارقام تشير الى
اصابه ثمانيه
ضابطا وجنديا في معارك قطاع غزه خلال
الساعات ال4 الاخيره احصاء كامل لعدد
المصابين يشير فيه الجيش الاسرائيلي الى
ارتفاع عدد الضباط والجنود المصابين منذ
بدايه الحرب الى
2748 ومنذ بدء الهجوم البري الى
1258 هذه الاعداد كيف تقيم في اسرائيل
يوميا وليد ما الذي تشكله من ضغط ايضا على
الجيش ومن ضغط ايضا على الحكومه
والمسؤولين
السياسي ذروه الخسائر في الارواح في الجيش
الاسرائيلي كانت قبل نحو اربعه ايام عندما
تعرضت قواته الى استهداف من قبل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه الشرقي مخيم المغازي وتحديدا
في مبنيين على بعد 600 متر فقط من الحدود
مع غلاف غز
وقتل في حادثتين هناك قصف للدبابه وقصف
للمباني التي انهارت عليهم بعد ان تفجرت
قتل 21 من الضباط والجنود وكان غيرهم في
نفس الوقت قد قتل ثلاثه من الضباط والجنود
وجرح ثلاثه اخرين في معارك بغربي خانيونس
ويوميا يكون يعلن الجيش عن ان لديه خسائر
اصابات تزيد على ال وال3 جنديا وضابطا
وهذه الخسائر حت حتى هذه الساعه لا يبدو
انها تؤثر على الاجماع الاسرائيلي بخصوص
مواصله الحرب لكنها ما تفعله انها تؤثر
على التيار او على ذوي الاسرائيليين
الاسرى والمحتجزين في قطاع غزه الذين
صعدوا من مواقف من حراكهم خلال الايام
الاخيره مطالبين بوقف تام لاطلاق النيران
وابرام صفقه تبادل سريعه وفوريه يتم في
اطارها اعاده جميع المحتجز ين هناك خشيه
من ان مواصله اسرائيل حربها واجتياحها
البري لقطاع غزه يؤدي الى مقتل اقربائهم
وابنائهم المحتجزين هذا الوضع زياده
الخسائر في الجيش الاسرائيلي كما كانت هذا
الاسبوع على وجه الخصوص ونحن نتحدث اليوم
عن اليوم 122 12ث قد رفع من عدد الجنود
والضباط الاسرائيليين الذين قتلوا منذ
عمليه طوفان الاقصى وبدايه الحرب في
السابع من اكتوبر الى
556 جنديا وضابطا قتيلا منهم
226 ضابطا وجنديا قتلوا منذ بدايه عمليه
الاجتياح البري في ال 26 من اكتوبر ومن
بين هؤلاء نحو 50 ضابطا وجنديا قتلوا منذ
بدايه العام الحالي وهذه تعتبر ارقام
عاليه جدا عند
الاسرائيليين لكنهم يحاولون الاظهار بانهم
مصممون على مواصله الحرب في غضون ذلك كله
يؤكد الجيش الاسرائيلي ان قواته ما زالت
تواجه ايضا قتالا ضاريا في جنوبي القطاع
لكنها ايضا مستهدفه من قبل خلايا او ما
يصفها بعمليه حرب عصابات في وسط قطاع غزه
وفي شمالي قطاع غزه ايضا الذي كان قد
احتله منذ ال 26 من اكتوبر الماضي تداعيات
ذلك على الشارع الاسرائيلي بانه اصبح هناك
اكثر تعزيزا نحو موقف ذوي الاسرائيليين
المحتجزين الذين يطالبون بوقف تام لاطلاق
النار وابرام صفقه تبادل مهما كان الثمن
حتى لو الكل في مقابل الكل في اشاره الى
احتمال انها تكون تشمل على اعاده او افراج
عن جميع الاسرائيليين الاسرى في قطاع غزه
في مقابل الافراج عن جميع الفلسطينيين
المعتقلين والاسرى في اسرائيل هذا الموضوع
هو محل خلاف متزايد داخل دائره صنع القرار
كان هناك حراك ايضا ل من جانب جهات تطالب
بالمضي في هذه الحرب دون توقف ودون انقطاع
هناك تهديدات من اوساط داخل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ممثله
بخاصه احزاب الصهيونيه الدينيه وكذلك
بالكود التي تقول يجب ان لا توقف الحرب
ويجب المضي بها حتى نهايتها وتحقيق
اهدافها لكن هناك تيار اخر يقول انه ان
الاان بعد 122 12 يوما الى وقف هذه الحرب
وابرام صفقه تبادل شامله وسحب القوات
الاسرائيليه الى الحدود هذه هي الفجوه
التي تزداد تعمقا بين التيارين سواء على
المستوى الشعبي او على المستوى صناع
القرار في اسرائيل اضيف الى هذه الارقام
ايضا وليد ما جاء في هذا البيان للجيش
الاسرائيلي بان
3696 ضابطا وجنديا ما زالوا يعالجون في
المستشفيات من بينهم
38 مصابون بجروح خطيره شكرا جزيلا لك وليد
العمري مدير مكتبنا من هناك نحو 3 الاف
منذ بدايه الحرب اصيبوا بعاهات مستديمه
ايضا واعترف بها الجيش شكرا
وليد